i
en perú rosa maría muñoz periodista de
23 años narró el partido de fútbol
masculino entre atlético grau de piura y
binacional lo hizo junto a las
comentaristas thalía azcárate y camila
zapata y se convirtieron en el primer
equipo de narración del fútbol
íntegramente femenino del país
más emocionante porque es como un
homenaje hacia los niños que alguna vez
soñó
durante la transmisión rosa maría muñoz
dejó claro que la narración no era una
cuota de género sino de talento ahora
han logrado un sueño que ya tiene un
nuevo reto narrar un partido de perú en
el mundial de qatar 2022
[Música]
del deporte como medio para una mayor
igualdad al deporte como un medio para
más tolerancia en tokio japon fue
inaugurada la casa del orgullo el primer
centro comunitario en ser oficialmente
reconocido por un comité olímpico
organizador
creo que el primer paso es que te
reconozcan y que la gente vea que
tenemos un problema eso es lo primero
después viene el siguiente paso para ver
cómo podemos hacer una sociedad y
cultura mejores
se espera que aprovechando los juegos
olímpicos' la casa del orgullo sea un
espacio de reunión información educación
y refugio para toda la comunidad lgtb
una nueva incorporación a la lucha de
viernes por el futuro de la activista
sueca greta samberg samela es una
estudiante brasileña de biología de 24
años y pertenece a la tribu indígena del
amazonas a tere magüey la lucha de sham
el a salvar la selva tropical para poder
salvar su tribu
y si perdemos todo esto moriremos como
consecuencia se trata de un eco
genocidio cuando muere una cultura
entonces necesitamos el bosque
necesitamos el amazonas
necesitamos el medio ambiente para que
todo esté en armonía y las cosas no
empiecen a colapsar
además samela participa en todo tipo de
actividades comunitarias elaborando
mascarillas anti cobit así como talleres
de manualidades con otras mujeres
indígenas en manaos un compromiso con
sus orígenes que comparte con la
convicción de que los pueblos indígenas
son los mejores guardianes de la
amazonas
[Música]
las telas desechadas en lagos nigeria
suelen terminar quemadas o arrojadas en
la laguna sin embargo marcelina apoyo a
sus 31 años se encarga de darles una
segunda vida a través del arte del
retrato
el material artístico es caro y sin
dinero no puedes conseguir ciertos
materiales estas telas estaban tiradas
así que empecé a usarlas para mis obras
combinándolo con el dibujo y apoyo toro
fue descubierta por la galería relé de
lagos o redes sociales hoy ha vendido
más de 100 piezas llegando a algunas de
sus obras hasta los 25 mil dólares
en bélgica están usando un aspirador
gigante para deshacerse de millones de
pedazos de basura plástica diminuta la
han estrenado en la reserva de galgos
air donde esperan que desaparezcan en un
enclave de marismas y aves en peligro de
extinción
i